Congratulations, you just did a lot of stuff. Let's do
a recap. You've wrote your first lines of code and
deployed it to App Engine. You got Conference Central up
and running. And you've tried out the API Explorer. Don't underestimate
the API Explorer. It's a great tool to use to
try out the APIs. And it's not limited to your
own APIs, you can use it for any Google API.
So, all good stuff. But let's now talk about user authentication.
Many applications require that a user is registered and
signed in before using the application. We will also require
this for Conference Central, so let's look at how
we do that. It used to be the case that
almost every application had to create their own user
management system. That would mean that you would have to
write all the code from scratch in order for
your users to use your applications. Well, good for us.
That is not needed anymore. With App Engine, you
can use third party authentication with Cloud Endpoints, such
as Google Plus sign-in. But also other ones can
be used. In Conference Central, we will require a Google
account for sign-in. So, how do we know that
the user is signed into their Google account when they
use Conference Central? That is actually taking care of
by Cloud Endpoints. A Cloud Endpoint's API method can optionally
take a user object as its first argument and
if the user object is not null then the
user is signed in, but if it's null then
we throw in exception which decline should receive and
redirect for sign in. Could it be more easy?
Hm, you might say now. But what about security
and privacy? Well, that is all taken care of
by Google Sign in or a third party authentication provider.
So this mechanism is the best of two worlds combined. A simple way
to add user authentication to your app, combined with the strong security and
privacy standards of Google, all right, that's enough talking, time for you do
some coding again by adding user
authentication to your Conference Central. Good luck.